and tom curran yesterday addressed why
this brady to the 49ers thing won't go
away
and the the two reasons he gave
i think make it abundantly clear why
there is smoke and indeed fire what kern
writes his first brady would love to
play there right that's a pretty
important dynamic kind of an free agent
decision i'd love to play there well
check that box second and this comes
from curran as much as niners coach kyle
shanahan likes garoppolo i've been told
by multiple sources he's got
reservations about garoppolo's sealing
and overall decision making which uh
look we saw the ceiling the ceiling is
somewhere below hitting a wide open
emanuel sanders with a championship on
the line because he had a chance to do
it he didn't period so uh if if that's
true if what current's saying is true
that's another reason for shanahan to
listen and and look chris i keep coming
back to this it doesn't have to be two
years with tom brady it can be a year
with brady right and then you go get
kirk cousins the guy that that kyle
shanahan wanted all along he's available
after this season unless he signs an
extension
no i you're you're exactly right there's
a lot of different ways you can go here
and you know yes the thing we don't know
right now is where shanahan's you know
heart really lies with garoppolo yeah
you hear those rumors i know he said a
lot of great things about him at the
combine and made a great a lot of great
points just talking about how baker
mayfield has started more games he came
off the acl injury you know he had a lot
of big moments but
if you're the 49ers organization and
you're shanahan and lynch and you don't
think jimmy garoppolo is the guy of the
future
then
you do entertain the tom brady
conversation and that's where we don't
know right now we don't know where the
49ers are at and their thought process
with jimmy g hey the super bowl as we
know you know i'm not going to sit here
and blame him but yeah it wasn't good we
know that it certainly could have been
better and he got outshined by a guy
that you know was special in my homes
but i think that's really gonna be the
dictating force to me if i'm in the
49ers organization is this guy the
future if he's not
okay
then i would for it with the tom brady
idea because you're thinking you're
gonna start new with something else here
in the next few years anyways right mike
the other thing i think that we need to
bring up here with a little connection
with the 49ers and uh tom brady you know
wes welker's with the san francisco
49ers yeah you got you can't so you
can't forget about that right he's out
there so if there's a lifeline or uh
anything there you know i'm sure there
could be conversations if it is real
between those two guys i mean that's
what i always do i always look at staffs
and things and go connect dots is there
a history between anybody here and of
course welker and brady is one that's
very prevalent and sticks out to me
yeah that's an excellent point and uh uh
look until and i think we're at the
point now
where the only way this fire is going to
be extinguished is to have a clear
unequivocal statement from the 49ers
that jimmy garoppolo is their guy and
they will not be pursuing any other
quarterbacks period that that's if the
cat that they they stuffed the cat in
the bag last week the cat is back out
and it's running all over the place and
let me just ask the control room for a
favor here put the graphic back up of
good jimmy bad jimmy we've got multiple
of these where we show the good stats
and the bad stats and we find you know a
flattering picture for good jimmy and
then we try to find an unflattering pick
there are no unflattering pictures
well yeah right so he's so he so even if
he gets run out of san francisco he's
still got that going for him at least
for another 15 or 20 yeah well he's got
that in common with brady you're not
gonna find a whole lot of bad pictures
of those guys and go wow they look
really funny and weird there
yeah and by brady standards he's got it
going for him for another what 30 or 40
years so uh
but but this is a fascinating
fascinating story and we have the
twitter poll that you can respond to and
we would like you to uh we already have
nearly 10 000 votes i just posted it
right before the show started today
where do you want to see tom brady play
in 2020 patriots titans 49ers somewhere
else are the choices patriots are
winning plurality yeah you can hear
plurality a lot in the coming months 41
plurality for patriots titans and 49ers
tied at 17. somewhere else what are you
five percent what do you want to say
somewhere else would be chaos yeah
i'll settle for the 49ers but i want the
cowboys i i want the patriots like i've
always said i want to see brady back
with the patriots and give it one more
run there but if it weren't the patriots
my second choice would be the 49ers
because i just think you could we could
go down an avenue of holy cow i mean yes
he's from there he goes to san francisco
what the hell happens to jimmy g i mean
does new england call you know call san
francisco if it gets down far down the
road and say hey we'll take jimmy g back
i mean that's where that's why i say the
49ers will be my second choice because
it could really
turn things on their head as far as this
quarterback free agency market
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights from nbc
sports